I have now relocated to the casino at
the Cosmopolitan Las Vegas and if you
are a fan of Game of Thrones this is the
place to be while you're waiting for the
show to premiere on April 14th because G
ot now has its own progressive slot
machines and if you want to you can also
place a bet on who you think will claim
the Iron Throne ET on lines Lee Ann
Aguilera was on the red carpet with all
the real-life contenders at the show's
premier I said to Rose the other night I
was like we've been tethered by this
show for a long time we've loved it and
now we get to enjoy the final hurrah
[Music]
ready
jujin are not the idea Nia I'm just
waiting for it so like hit me like a
freight train
bringing eight seasons to a close last
night's premiere was definitely
emotional for this cast and a time to
reflect
especially for emilia clark who recently
revealed she suffered two brain
aneurysms in between shooting the show
why was it important for you to share
your story because i just want to help
people i want to make them feel not
alone because they're not the only ones
who have experienced something like that
and i felt like i had an opportunity to
do that very sad cause i'm slahser
numerous times i love her to bits there
are happier times ahead though Sofie
Turner's upcoming wedding to Joe Jonas
is going to be a game of Thrones family
affair amazing Kit Harington is hosting
SNL this weekend how do you think he's
gonna do am I going kids like North
honey it's gonna be hilarious
I love Don a shot so my name's kit no in
fact that's a day-night how are you
preparing just dumb to read to I'm like
chopped on a suit and came here it's
brilliant oh damn
[Music]
[Applause]